ich entschuldige mich für meinen noch
beschissener als sonst wegen das
erscheinungsbild allerdings bin ich
erkältet und ich hab mir gedacht dass
eventuell das eine oder andere lokal ihm
meine laune ein wenig steigern kann und
dann würde ich direkt sagen fangen wir
an mit einem ihm in der lehrer dich
fragt weshalb du mal wieder deine
hausaufgaben vergessen hast
[Musik]
dass das kann ich erklären war wieder
member dieser moment wenn man ein wort
so sehr falsch schreibt dass selbst der
autokorrektur die ideen ausgehen
das ist der grund warum ich die
autokorrektur bei meinem handy gar nicht
aktivierte aber nichts ist mehr fähig
als der applaus von der klasse nach
einer präsentation und das ist wirklich
die wahrheit dieser moment wenn der
sitznachbar redet und du ärger bekommst
im nächsten ihm geht es darum wenn man
kein geld hat sich sachen aus dem lukas
shop.de zu kaufen
halb monat nichts essen ja ist auch
wieder die wahrheit wenn zwei veganer
sich streiten ist es dann immer noch wie
froh man kommt ihm ein tier das ernst
mit diesem wissen was ist wenn nur der
aufkleber made in china in china
hergestellt
[Musik]
j
meine weltanschauung bricht zusammen
kannst du mir fünf euro geben meine
mutter was ist mit den fünf euro
passiert die ich dir vor zehn jahren
gegeben habe ich kann ich lachen weil
sonst meinen als explodiert habe ich hab
einfach den krone an die usa steht eine
mülltonne ja auch da auch da auch da
auch ich habe nun einmal hunger
ja
das ist meine schulzeit zusammengefasst
in einem video hat meinem freund
geratenen limo witz erzählt fanta lustig
hat echt einer ins humor hirn geschissen
wenn man mit flip-flops rückwärts läuft
heißen die dampflok lips
sammer
er sprach
ich weiß nicht was mit deiner
weltanschauung kapitel das ist
hundertprozentig die wahrheit englisch
ist niemals rot gewesen sondern gelb und
deutsches rot und mathematik ist blau
wenn es woanders war dann schreibt man
gerne eure farbfächer aufteilung und in
die kommentare aber ich werde euch dann
einfach ins gesicht scheiße wenn dir
jemand was sagst du es aber nicht
verstehst und dann lächelt und hofft das
ist keine frage war okay das ist wieder
absolut puzzle die ganze zeit meine
lunge und leber und dickdarm alles muss
nicht aus denn der taxi fahrer rückwärts
fährt muss sich dann weniger zahlen nein
der taxifahrer musste dann aber geld
geben lehrer doppelpunkt ich will mal
andere finger oben ist neben luca doppel
und wie kommt die auf so eine scheiße
[Musik]
wahrheit hundertprozentig die die
wahrheit was ist das gegenteil von
katalog kater sagte die wahrheit
wow also ihr habt echt comedy preis von
hinten verdient apropos preis allerdings
meine lieben freunde ein ganz kurzer
exkurs in dem podcast welt und zwar im
sandra und ich ja den dick und doof
podcast von dem es gerade auch eine neue
folge online gegangen und zwar die
community folge allerdings wollte ich
nur ganz kurz sagen dass da noch nicht
nominiert sind für den verdammt nochmal
deutschen podcast preis also einen link
findet ihr oben in der video
beschreibung hab di gern mal auf klick
darauf ihr müsst euch links voranmelden
dem ist einfach noch abstimmen klicken
und würde uns damit einen riesigen
gefallen tun allerdings machen wir jetzt
weiter mit diesen mini und zwar ich
doppelt kann ich auf toilette gehen
lehrer ich weiß nicht ob du kannst ja
das waren dann die richtig witzigen
lehrer luca 23 regt sich über eine
gemalte rose auf auch luca malt eine
libelle die aussehen wie ein salatkopf
ich fühle mich wie so ein backstein
immer noch im siebten stockwerk wir wie
nennt man es wenn du einen salto machste
salto fragezeichen nein bottle flip weil
du eine flasche bist wer denkt sich
diese scheiße bei euch aus ich hätte mal
eine frage an die runde die heißt sandra
du arschloch
okay was ich mich schon lange frage ist
ist luca jetzt ein lappen oder einen
lauf
ich glaube ich habe das kranke talent
dass sich beides bin
was ich eigentlich tun sollte wenn ich
krank wenn es im bett liegen
als sich allerdings stattdessen mache
ist
hier sitzen und müll content für euch
produzieren jemand doppelpunkt du musst
geduldiger werden luca doppelpunkt
dauert das lange okay das ist das ist
leider wieder absolut die wahrheit was
bekommen stille hunde den nobelpreis
meint ihr doch nicht ernst
[Musik]
ich sage nicht was das ist wenn du luft
kaufst und dann die halbe packung chips
ich will überhaupt nicht wieso ein
bemitleidenswertes opfer klingen aber
warum ging adele über die straße um
hello von der anderen seite zu singen
der gab könnt ihr mir bitte alle and
folgen wenn mich leute fragen was geht
ab male ich ihnen einiges auf die stirn
und sage aging schon mal nicht
das ist doch nicht euer verdammter ernst
oder
vorher nachher ariel entfernt selbst den
allergrößten dreck könnt ihr euch nicht
alle einfach verpissen wie nennt man
eine iphone hülle apfel
[Musik]
ich dachte diese - kurbeln meine laune
an aber jetzt fühle mich einfach wie
zwei backsteine die aus dem 110 stock
gestützt werden die leute in der schule
in deutsch stehe ich auf zwei das ist
doch super na ja die haben beide einen
ey
ihr seid glaube ich nie mehr zu retten
name doppelpunkt luca vorname
doppelpunkt ich bin zu blöd formulare
auszufüllen dass die wahrheit
dabei brauche ich nicht zu sagen wenn
mich jemand fragt was ich den ganzen tag
über mache wahrheit lukas kisten sind
nach zehn minuten ausverkauft luca
doppelpunkt
[Musik]
warum schaut ihr euch das sie gerade an
was sagt die kuh zum polizisten mein
mann ist auch bohlen kommt bitte geht
einfach ich wenn ich über sinnloses und
dummes zeug nachdenke weil ich nicht
schlafen kann er das ist schon blöd wenn
man tot ist und dann liegt man dem sagen
ist es auch noch zu dunkel und zu eng da
drin er ist halt ja die wahrheit dieser
moment wenn der lehrer dir was erklärt
und währenddessen in ein heft kritzelt
er noch einfach nicht dazu
sandra warum schickst du dich um drei
uhr nachts damit ich meine nachrichten
lesen okay okay der ist gut er ist gut
wir haben euch viele da draußen jetzt
gar nicht verstanden aber es geht um
face id
also glaube ich zumindest
absolute wahrheit leute doppelpunkt ich
habe nur schlechtes über mich gehört ich
doppelpunkt angehe und höher gutes ja
ist die wahrheit wenn du jemanden um 16
uhr ein drei minuten langes video
schicks und die person hat um 16 01 mid
hh reagiert das ist auch wieder die
wahrheit sorry dass ich nicht zurück
geschrieben habe war voll im stress
doppelpunkt
ich diese ganze video bestehen darauf
dass ich sage das ist die wahrheit ist
aber es auch hier wieder die wahrheit
wie betrinken sich mücken insekt
ihr könntet eigentlich meine wohnung
hier nach köln kommen einfach aus dem
fenster springen nennen sich maikäfer am
ende des mais im juni kehrt als frau
wenn man denkt dass man einzigartig ist
aber dann seinen benutzern namen
eingeben muss das ist tatsächlich wieder
die wahrheit wie ich mich fühlen nachdem
ich zwei liegestütze geschafft habe
das ist auch wieder die wahrheit habe
gestern einen cent gefunden und ihn
heute wieder verloren war es jetzt ein
one night
nicht schlimmer als als ich zeige euch
jetzt noch fünf teams hintereinander
hier zum ende was ist der unterschied
zwischen deinen eltern und einem crash
deine eltern lieben dich auch jemand
doppelpunkt beschreiben sie die deutsche
sprache ich doppelpunkt umfahren ist das
gegenteil von umfahren was meine freunde
und ich machen wenn wir im schwimmbad
sind
ich habe gerade beim bäcker angerufen da
ging aber nur die mailbox ran wenn man
einen anwalt einschaltet leuchtet er
dann
wenn es euch ansatzweise so toll
gefallen hat wie mir und lass daumen
hoch in kommentaren da und ich geh jetzt
kotzen
[Musik]